okay we have a voicemail number and that
number is two one nine two david p you
can call absolutely any time that you
would like here's a caller from hawaii
who gets some of the numbers wrong but
still makes a good point let's take a
listen hey david this is ron out in
hawaii I'm on the Big Island of Hawaii
right June 17 20 20 we haven't had a
case of coronavirus in days maybe weeks
so that's not true in fact if you look
at the numbers you see that Hawaii has
had new cases every single day but very
very few very very few and yet when I go
out and I drive around and I go to
public places people are wearing masks
we have no cases right Island and people
are following protocol people are making
sure to keep 6-foot distance so when I
see reports of Texas and Arizona people
pretending that there's no virus right I
really can't understand why and it makes
me so happy that I decided to move to an
island in the middle of the Pacific
Ocean
Durst oh I think we got cut off there I
I totally get the feeling listen I I'm
not in an isle on an island in
Massachusetts but I I'm also very glad
that I'm here and not in you know Texas
or AZ Arizona or Florida or wherever
else so Hawaii does have some cases I
was just looking at the numbers before
coming on on air but they have very few
they've managed it very very well and
people listen that the guidelines work
that's the reality the guidelines work
and you can say what you want about
death rates or mortality or age or any
of this other stuff the guidelines work
and you've got to stick to them and just
having the guidelines isn't enough you
actually need buy-in from people to do
the things that you are asking them to
do and my fear is I take no pleasure in
this because then any death is a death
it's all horrible my fear is that what
we're going to see in some of these
states that have decided we're just not
shutting down it's just not happening no
matter what happens we may be seeing
things that are even worse than anything
we've seen so far in some of
state's upcoming increasingly increasing
warnings about ICU and hospital capacity
being stressed to the absolute max in
some states it's bad um and the the
question will be will it start to bleed
over into the states that are doing the
right things because of interstate
travel we don't know we're going to
watch all of this stuff very very
closely okay we have a tremendous bonus
show for you today get the bonus show by
becoming a member at join pakman.com or
patreon.com slash david pakman show and
remember that the daily audio podcast is
always available if you watch on YouTube
or Facebook clips and you would rather
just get the full hour audio podcast
it's available for free on iTunes
stitcher google play podcasts Spotify
Pandora it's almost too available it's
too easy to get the audio podcast
subscribe to it for free and get the
daily show every single day